- There's only like a few
people, I think, in the world
that can keep up with us and I
think are funny and I think
Martellus Bennett’s one of those guys
- Why, thank you. I think
that's a compliment
- Yeah
- It was a weird compliment
- Your brother, too
- Yeah
- He can be that with us too. Yeah, that would have been good.
- Yeah, you’re two of our favorites
- You know, the grape doesn't fall far from the vine
- Oooh
- That's what they say, yes
- I like since it’s not a quarterback
I get to sit next to him too
- Right
- And also, I think this is
the Eagles fans now
- Well, I don't know
- He's officially an Eagles fan
- I am an Eagles fan
- I hear ya. Jump on the bandwagon.
- I’m not—no, I’m a Michael Bennett fan
- Yes
- And he plays for the Eagles
- So, therefore, he plays for the Eagles
so I’m rootin’ for him to do well, so I’m rootin’ for them to do well
- Yes, OK
- I still think “Fly, Eagles, Fly” is the worst song ever written by anyone
- [Laughing]
- Next to the national anthem
- Right
- Really?
- Next to the national anthem?
- Coming out hardcore
- Do you like the E-A-G-L-E-S at the end, though?
- No, I don’t like any of it
- But wait
- I mean, if I played for them, I would love it
- Perfect
- But you’re a fan now
- It’s like saying if I liked country music, I would love country music
but I don’t like country music
- Damn
- What was it like Sunday being a fan?
It’s like your first time now
- I didn’t watch much football Sunday
- What did I do on Sunday? Sunday…oh, I was at Harvard.
- Ohhhh
- Excuse me
- So that’s where you got the sweatshirt
- Yeah, you know, just like when you go to New York,
you get an “I Heart New York” shirt
- No, nobody does that
- No, I lived in Boston and never got a Harvard shirt
- But you never went to Harvard
- I did too
- And you were never part of their crossover program
- No, that I was not, for sure. But I did go over there.
- Yeah, see, I’m part of an MBA program over there, so I felt like
it was official, even though I’m not a Harvard student
- Wow
- Gotcha
- I realized I woulda did very well in those classes—besides the point
that you have to raise your hand to ask questions. I just don’t get that s- -t.
- Oh
- You don’t believe in that?
- I’m too old for that s- -t
- Did you ever get Bill to laugh?
- Cuz you're a funny dude
- Oh I made Bill laugh several times
- Is there one that comes to mind?
- Nah, he laughed so often around me
- That’s impressive
- The key was to get him to smirk. So if you get him to smirk
like he’s about to laugh but he
doesn’t laugh, then you know that he
was laughing in his heart. You know?
- [Laughing]
- I know the smirk you’re talking about
- Yeah, that good smirk
- That’s all he’s gonna give you
- It’s like a respect, like
“Yeah, that s- -t’s funny, but I ain’t gonna laugh at it”
- Yeah, right
- “But that’s a good one, Marty”
- “For staying back to the details here”
- Yeah
- Our first Sunday was not the same
That’s why he’s a lot cooler than me
- What do you mean?
- I mean, my first Sunday without football,
I was a wreck. I was cryin’.
- Really?
- I was, like, the exact
opposite. I was watching every
game and like, “I can’t believe this
guy's playing and I'm not”
- So I was wondering this, though
- Yeah?
- Is it different when you retire
when you want to retire, and
when the league pushes you out?
- I think so, and they pushed me out
- See, I retired when I wanted. I was done.
- Again, you’re cooler
- So I’m happy with what I did
You know, a lot of guys, I think they’re—I don’t
want to say bitter, necessarily
- Right
but they’re bitter about someone else being in.
They feel like they still
could do it. They could still go play. Then
you go try out
for the Canada team when you’re 42
- No, never. Not happening.
- No, he wouldn’t
- No, NFL or nothing
- Yeah, so yeah, I get that.
But for me it’s just been—I’ve
been the happiest I’ve ever been as
a—well, I’ve been happy before
but I’m happier
- Like, I'm happy happy.
- Like, as a human, happy
- Like a happy human being. Like, man,
I get to do whatever I wanna do,
- Eat whatever you want
- Get to smoke weed, not worry about getting tested
- I hear ya
- I have cake for breakfast, you know
all kinds of shit. And it just—like, I get to draw all day
and I’m on my own time
- Yeah
- And I own my day. Like, I could meet my wife
for margaritas in the middle
of the day, which is so awesome
cuz in football, for eight months,
you can never go to lunch
with your wife
- Right
- So you eat cake for breakfast?
- Every once in a while, just to
remind myself that I’m in
charge of my life.
- [Laughing]
- Tell the universe Marty’s for real
- Yeah
- Well, one other thing about New England that I find
fascinating, cuz you're one of the
freakiest tight ends I've ever seen
and been around, just cuz of
your size, speed, blocking combo
but you were there with another
freak of nature.
- Yeah
- Like, was that
weird for you at first to be like, “Damn, this guy's as big as me
He moves like me”
- So, it’s interesting cuz when I first met Rob
I was doing MMA in L.A.
and he was in the same gym. We were working out.
He came in, and he’s like, “Is all that sweat?”
And I was like, “Yeah, motherfucker, I get it in”
You know what I’m saying? He's like, “Oh, me too”
- [Laughing]
- You know, it’s kinda like
how we bonded right there, you know.
Like, we work hard.
- [Laughing]
- Such a Gronk response. “I sweat too! That's amazing!”
- “I’ve never met anyone that sweats more than me!”
I was like
“Yeah, Rob, I’m out here grindin’.” He’s like,
“I like that, I like that!”
And then, like, a day later, I got traded
to the Patriots. Even though we
were similar, we’re also so much
different.
- Yeah
- You know what I’m sayin’?
And that’s the one thing I thought Josh did very well
I was like, “Josh, I like to get the
ball in my hands early so I can
turn around and do what I do with
the ball. Gronk likes the deeper routes.
- Yes
- So we matched very well. So there was Gronk routes
and there was Marty routes. And my coach, Daboll, was very
good because he didn't try to
treat us the same or coach us the same.
So there was some, like
He’d be like, “Hey, Marty, look at this Gase
tape,” which I appreciate when
coaches bring you other
people's tape. He’s like, “I just wanna watch
you watch these 20 cut-ups and see
if there’s any routes
cuz I think some of those are ones
you’ll wanna add to your game”
- Right
- Any time a coach comes to you, like,
“We wanna add something to your game”
You’ll be like, “I’m down there for it.” And there's not
a lot of coaches that do that
- People don't realize that.
People think that all coaches
are created equal, and they're not
- They're not. No, they’re not.
- At all
- No, they’re not. I mean, Gronk liked
it too because we balanced
each other out very well. And I
think we liked each
other because we both could block
- Yeah
- Cuz nothing’s
worse than being the only tight end
that can block and one guy
just runnin’ all the routes, and you can catch the ball too
- “Yeah, I’ll bash my head
against Julius Peppers over here
You go get fantasy points”
- I hate that shit. I don’t like that shit.
- I hear ya
- Like, if you can’t, don’t fuckin’ put him in if
they can’t even do everything
I’m OK with guys eatin’, but at the same time,
like, you gotta be doin’ everything at the position
Don't come in and let him run a deep route so I can
fake the pass protection
- [Laughing]
- You were talking earlier about
retiring when you want and
being forced out. I feel like
I'm looking at Dez, and I’m seeing the
tweets, and I can see the
frustration. What the hell’s happening with Dez right now?
-I think there's
a perception, right, that these
perceptions, these teams could
build perceptions about players
- Mhmm
- Right, and if you take a meeting
and you don't kill that
perception in that meeting, they
start to believe what everyone else has said
- It becomes reality
- Yeah, it becomes your reality
So I think with Dez, his thing—
I think that, you know, trying to
control the situation, but at the
same time, the best thing you can
do to control the situation is just
chill. Physically, you can still play
People sign Eric Decker
- Yes
- And, you know, there’s
receivers getting signed all the
time
- No, the talent’s there
- Same thing with, like, an Eric Reid.
- Come on
- There's safeties getting signed
that can’t play better than Eric Reid. It’s just
like, “But you’re gonna pass up on this guy?”
- End game, though, how do you see
Dez and, like, the end game here
because I don't want him to go
too long without playing here
too, cuz, like, I like Dez too.
I don't think he's a superstar
anymore. But I want to see him
on the field, and he deserves to be
on the field
- And to play with a quarterback—I think the
personality of the quarterback is
gonna make Dez a better player
- Right
- Right? So playin’ with a Tom Brady or playin’ with a
- Philip Rivers?
- A Philip Rivers, who has that fire
- Yes
- And can match Dez’s fire, and he believes in
that fire
- Yeah
- It’s gonna be a better situation for him because
he’s gonna have—they’re gonna have that
mutual respect for one another, as far as competitors
- Right
- All these coaches talk about, they
want guys who love football
Like, let’s get some football guys in
here, but when you have a
guy who loves football so much, they label
him as a guy that’s, like, a diva.
But he just wants to win, he wants
to play, and he loves playing
football. So, if you can get those
three things outta most guys, cuz
most guys don't really love it
the way they say they love it. They
just say that shit until they
get the check, cuz most of these people
aren’t who they really say they
are. It’s just a facade.
- Yeah, some fugazis
- Yeah, they just play the
game very well. I wasn't into
playing that game. I was into playing
the game of football. But
you gotta win at the game
of life as well, so I f- -k with it, you
know what I’m sayin’?
- [Laughter]
- Did this feel good for you?
- What?
- This. I mean, this threesome we’re having
- Yeah, did you have fun?
- Yeah
- Yeah, I like talking to you guys
You guys are some of my favorite
- You’re our homie, man, just so you know
- Yeah
- Like, we’ve talked about you and
your brother, like, nonstop
for the last few years
- All the time, yeah
- I appreciate your pink nails. I appreciate your new—
- What?
- You didn’t see that?
- I did not
- Well, so what happened was
this is the last thing I tell the people of the
show. So I got ready to do TV last week
and my daughter thought my nails
needed to be done, so she
painted them pink. And I was like, “Cool.”
As a good father, that’s the kinda shit
you do. You do tea parties, and you
do, you paint nails with each other.
And you leave your nails pink
cuz that’s what daddies and
daughters do, you know?
- That’s awesome
- Good for you.
- But when she painted it, she used
to have the cheap polish, but
now that she's older, it’s not the
kind that peels off. And no one
in the house seems to have
fingernail polish remover because
everyone goes to the nail salon to
get their nails done
- [Laughter]
- So I’ve been trying to chip it off away for almost, like, two
weeks, and I'm just so busy that
I never think about it, and I
actually started liking it a little bit
- I kind of dig it
- [Laughter]
- Well, it’s not perfect, and it’s messed up. It’s like—
- Looks like you’re an artist
- I’m a free spirit. I’m an artist.
- Yeah, she just added to my branding
- Martellus, we appreciate you, man, again.
Check out Martellus’ show
“Mostly Football”—Yahoo?
- And Complex, and my new podcast called
“Revenge of the Jocks”
- Almost as many jobs as you
- Ooh, “Revenge of the Jocks”
I wanna get a little somethin’ here
- Oh, man, I thought I was the only one that was gonna get one
- He has a little more flavor than you.
You're, like, you know
like, you don’t have as much cacao
-Yeahhh, he knows white chocolate when he sees it!
- [Laughter]
- I wasn’t ready for that
- I hope we got that!